pop
[Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au pg entités vie a lâché tout cas assez
mexique un tacle à pied noir on peut
tout de même pas que j'en bouffe et du
steak frites à macau bricole on regarde
ce que tu manges la tension installé
c'est pourquoi manger à midi - oui alors
là j'ai passé des heures à la table des
coûts' et l'espionnage moderne c'est ça
devient du fonctionnariat même voyagé
beaucoup j'étais marin au long cours
ça serait pire ou alors un spéléologue
sous la terre non il faut au niveau
différent chérie je suis pas un homme
comme les autres par des services
ils te demandent jamais d'aller coucher
avec une espérance aux critiques
non ça c'est bon pour les romans
d'avant-guerre comme quoi dans le match
j'ai lu qu'il y avait souvent des
histoires d'homosexuels oui j'ai visité
des anglais on dit dans les abruzzes ton
truc contre-pouvoir
qu'est ce que tu fabriques et calcule
une intégrale au sein de lui plus rien
ne m'étonne
je ferai de toi un financier comme ça du
phrasé toute la famille petits dont ça
me reposerai un peu moins et dans 3500
francs de loyer 2000 francs de gaz
électricité mille francs de téléphone
plus la bouffe les frusques le trimestre
des gosses les vacances étaient soldes t
fameux sol un
eh ben ça va bien écoles de mépriser de
l'argent zani putsch al hijja django
unchained chouchou ou tonnes qui était
un petit goût il faisait que tu racontes
là c'est une pensée le président m'a le
pape admet prix sur l'argent c'est pour
cela qu'il vaincra les impérialistes
profiteurs du prolétariat
moi je t'attends à la fameuse tu dois te
la russie ont même acheté chez le
pâtissier non gérés
je vais
tu vas pas t'endormir comme je suis
crevée c'est pour les espionnes
soviétique même dans cet état maintenant
je te le dis je suis un top écoute si ce
n'est que la platée coup d'envoi par
saint siège il est gay nar je n'ai pas
et 6 heures où tu vas un je m'en vais à
orly je cherchais à nos agents qui
arrive du brésil et bien après le
connais il m'envoie en mission encore
mais vous ça je sais pas et il doit me
le dire au nouveau dernièrement
d'accord je sais pas non plus mais sert
à défendre mais donc ça va pas être
longue
je pense que je serai de retour samedi
encore j'ai tout dépensé ce que j'avais
donnée la semaine dernière me tu rigoles
ou tu te rends pas compte
j'ai payé les cours d'hervé les
ramoneurs le plombier tient pour la fidh
dans les wc j'ai acheté une paire de
chaussures à clous et comme lui ça file
euros ça je sais c'est pour ça qu'il
faut que je fasse des missions spéciales
à cause des primes de risque
non mais oh mon cher enfant ma tante
n'en attendait pas moins
vous avez beaucoup manqué ma tête comme
c'est délicat
alors comment s'est passé votre petit
séjour personnel et des lectures ainsi
qu' une nourriture déplaisant et je ne
parle pas les fréquentations
aujourd'hui on arrête vraiment
d'importance le pauvre fille s'en
servent à nous même pas parler
présentation juste des rencontres de
couloir oui on continue ici qu'on fasse
oui ça s'est même amélioré par rapport à
la roquette certes à parlons d'autre
chose vous voulez vous mon cher petit
comment va l'institut couci couça les
rosaces de la chance ça part toujours
oui ça marche pas mal mais alors la
publicité nous coûtent les yeux de la
tête
pendant mes loisirs forces et j'ai eu
quelques idées
oh ça j'en doute pas ma tante avec vous
les machinations est toujours au pouvoir
des petits sachets aphrodisiaques par
exemple avoir en tisane oui ce genre de
chose intéresse un nombre incalculable
de gens mais je les projets plus
ambitieux et dans les médias m'attendre
je vous conduis ou chez moi j'aimerais
faire une tête parce que les produits de
beauté à la cantine de fresnes c'est
inimaginable avant des produits qu'on
demande même dans les supermarchés de la
vérité ensuite ma tante je vous
emmènerai chez notre ami l'auvergnat ah
oui pour faire oublier épouse infâme de
l'administration pénitentiaire voilà les
un coeur généreux et norbert un garçon
d'élite suite est qu'on m'avait forme et
ma tante votre meilleur disciple
allez on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque écoute tu veux la faire à tête
quelle bonne surprise valable la baronne
[Musique]
les hommages parole j'espère que madame
la baronne a passé un bon séjour sur des
terres maroc autorisera avec thé à sa
table on a parlé de choses très
sérieuses on est bonne mais je vous tue
le franc en coin je prends le train
orient-express nos excuses moi janot et
on fait 10 à demain à toute façon c'est
ma théorie ne peut pas sortir dé même
chose au bout si on prenait un petit
apéro pour fêter votre retour parmi nous
compenserons la bonne nouvelle du jour
c'est du lapin chasseur tout même mieux
que le poulet été désavoué
ça c'est vous l'avez dit des mots
chantreuil menacent d'y aller tous un
quai des orfèvres porter plainte comment
ils n'avaient pas payé depuis le mois de
septembre
non maintenant mon beau pays alors
madame la baronne ça fait plaisir de
vous revoir
c'était bien la valentine argentine
c'est toujours mieux l'argentine mais
elle connaissait il ya déjà été il n'ya
qu'une chose que je regrette lorsque je
suis à buenos aires
c'est la cuisine française rien ne vaut
votre lapin chasseur et vos tripes ou
d'auvergne cher monsieur
bon l'élu n'a qui lisent l'avenir nous
pourrions quand les vents dans un but
public le buvard qui boit les fautes
d'orthographe
ça devrait marcher en afrique
francophone reste notre rose a de la
chance elle garde son impact sur le
public
vous avez raison d'ambert le mot rosa
c'est une sonorité une résidente du
mystérieux ce que croient qu'ils
pouvaient sans doute choqué les
sentiments religieux de nos clients
catholique
bon enfin il ya quand même des grâces
bon dans la mécanique barral est ce
monsieur j'ai acheté votre rosas il ya
quatre mois contrairement à vos
indications gelé constaté aucune
amélioration dans l'arthrose
mon rôle en retrait mais s'agit-il d'une
vulgaire escroquerie est rentré juillet
deux fois j'ai de la chance que l'on
aime ont pu rentrer à quoi est ce genre
de connard peut nous conduire
d'où vous venez barron's met tout ce qui
rapporte un peu comporte quelques
risques
la nuit d'art et ont traqué les tirs et
que votre prochain texte de publicité
près le voilà ma tante
larosace de la chance larosace bio
tellurique à l'incantation étrange mens
sana in corpore sano
ce talisman bio vital agit sur vous
aussi bien quand vous avec une force
cosmique bio tellurique inégalé tout à
fait au point mais nous voulions par
contre dans les champs d'application
retirer ma tempe
la science ne saurait se contenter d'un
cas isolé mon cher norbert je vous fais
confiance
tout ceci est réglé il faut que nous
parlions d'autres choses
je pense que le moment est venu de
monter la sphère d'hélium aux gentils
encore à battre si c'est ça le résultat
de mon grand-père jory derrière les
barreaux mais les diamants jonquilles
c'est le coût des boucles d'oreilles ça
a été fait 126 fois tous les bijoutiers
du monde sont au parfum
tout est une question de persuasion de
présentation prenez les hommes
politiques ne distille pas toujours tous
la même chose
andrus et l'imprimeur monsieur jean
entre quelle bonne surprise
j'ai pas vraiment plus chaud et froid
qu'il fait chou blanc dont il nous
appelait en devenir
ces lignes pour vous ne prenez pas
croire qu'on voit aujourd'hui je retiens
donc je ne voulais plus je veux à mon
prénom je vous ai demandé un petit délai
qui tombe ça fait plus d'un an que
j'attends et s'imbriquent vous appelez
ça un petit délai c'est toujours la même
période autant que je ne partirai pas
sans mon fric
écoutez je rentre et on vous demande un
dernier répit de 15 jours pas un jour de
plus ça vous donne ma parole
on est sur une affaire très important je
les connais vous avez un très important
un infarctus qui attend quoi oui bah
c'est parce que c'est pareil
vous savez à l'avancé quand votre au
cimetière côté vous le truand feriez
mieux de vous tenir à carreau nos maux
de tête non monsieur je croyais y
présenter écouter et 3
je vous faire [ __ ] en taule les
bâtiments a plus de confiance
escroquerie
j'en passe et des meilleurs je n'en
avais jamais fait de prison j'ai lu les
journaux
j'en ai près de bonn sur vaud l'a fait
de belle carrière avec le luigi della
torre est là après la guerre ouais les
diamants demi siècle pour les tours de
passe passe et tout cela par hunt
beaufumé parente de mes fesses we do ré
pour être poli avec les doigts parce que
sans ça je veux faire le t3 ont décidé
beaucoup chantreuil êtes très grossier
vous prêter l'oreille aux calomnies les
plus odieuses vous mettez en doute mes
titres de noblesse fait beaucoup de
peine
elle est belle la noblesse oui monsieur
j'en suis fier mois barone victoire de
beauf humer quant à mon neveu norbert
c'est son père qui a décidé de retirer
la particule afin d'échapper aux
persécutions les plus hostiles
juste avant sa mort il m'a confié la
garde de son petit norbert chantreuil
vous nous a foncé gravement khoury
gravement
bon parlons plus je veux bien vous
croire - et ça me rend bronchera pas ce
que vous me devez 1 millions en liquide
ou de suite et leur aise en 15 jours sa
voix bah ouais encore bien posséder un
nom mais non nous sommes entre gens du
monde norbert servi nous quelque chose
oui voilà près du sol et chantreuil tout
m
salut baroness et réfléchissez bien les
gens qui moi je trouve ça grandit devant
parce que je n'en dis moi c'est tout
réfléchi ferme dans l'affairé danse
la nuit porte conseil tout de même enfin
je suis content bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
ne vous fatiguez pas soyez sans crainte
je t'assure que son histoire de gens qui
c'est foireux je la sens pas rom elle a
le chic pour me plais de pigeons pour la
wii mais les pigeons il y en a tout de
même qu'il réussisse à s'échapper du
piège qui vont payer chéri flic est la
preuve
elle revient pour les primaires on verra
bien toute façon toi tu risque rien moi
c'est pareil
ceux qui sont dehors souffre des fois
beaucoup plus que ceux qui sont dedans
on retrouve sa jarretière pas assez
comme ça mon mieux
si oui oui ah bonjour comment ça va
sébastien des baignots pas bonjour
pascal alors des bottes noires
le shérif a apporté ça pour vous ça
c'est pour ces danseurs et un ça va
mais bon on va chez toi tu es parti tu
ne t'es pas comme ça qu'ils avaient un
blouson avec un polo ah oui je passais
en vitesse mais ma femme n'était pas la
salle à manger rorty nantes enfoncé si
j'étais pas menti mais sa maman en ce
moment j'ai tellement de choses en tête
tellement de trucs à faire que je me
retrouve plus elles sont jolies à vendre
a mis les mains dans l'eau tout de suite
les toits mais après tout je me demande
pourquoi tout voir très clair je sais
pas c'est normal d'offrir des fleurs à
une femme c'est pourquoi pas le
contraire m'aurait traiteront abbas est
pas moins les femmes et les fleurs ça va
bien ensemble je voudrais me réalisés
m'exprimer tu comprends tu peux dire à
mes propres besoins
nos propres besoins allé battre des
gentils quand même et puis tout ça te
fait plaisir
la prochaine fois c'est toi qui m'as
n'offrira mais ça reviendra au même
puisque elles resteront ici et que c'est
avec ton fait que je les perdrais
puisque tout est compliqué tu t'occupes
des enfants c'est déjà pas mal
et ma créativité dans tout ça et moi tu
crois que je crée mon et ben c'est
peut-être pas de la création mais je
vends des films c'est pareil que si je
vendais des locomotives des aspirateurs
en gros de vaud des meubles enfin nous
importe quoi si seulement tu me trouvais
un petit rôle
oui non mais de toute façon dans tout ce
que je fais moi je vois que distributeur
les financiers la semaine prochaine je
veux retourner à francfort j'espère bien
faire une belle affaire
tu projettes acheter l'appartement
ces propos ne vais pas un petit temps
meilleurs allez senna social et citoyen
voilà qui l'a eu mais alors pas roulé sa
bosse située entre 80 rien allez adorent
mais ce qui est important c'est d'en
donner le goût de la liberté
ah ben tu vois les enfants de tazoult
liberté peu importe nous ne sommes plus
au temps du paternalisme abusive et à
claques sur la fesse peu traumatisés
parce qu'à ont donc un aller non mais tu
veux rire mons il fallait que je compte
les faits c'est que dans une victoire va
donner quand j'étais petit c'est
peut-être pour ça que tu es complexé jeu
complexe et moi tu me fatigues et était
en rien un de nos titres ont cassé des
arguments bonjour sans toi c'est long
une belle survient qu'une bonne part
[Musique]
magan je voudrais parler à votre
directeur
pardonnez moi si vous voulez bien vous
donner la peine de vous asseoir madame
la grande duchesse
mes hommages madame la grande duchesse
acquis et jon monsieur martin directeur
commercial il faut que vous sachiez
pourquoi je veux vous entretenir
monsieur voilà il s'agit d'un miracle si
tumultueusement trafic du revenait de
chez mon coiffeur dans le faubourg
saint-honoré en passant par la vente au
machinalement je m'arrête devant votre
étalages et que ce jour à la vôtre
jean-guy diamant l'un des plus beaux
joyaux qui soit au monde voulait dire
notre diamant jaune qui n'a je
m'aperçois que madame la grande duchesse
un goût très sûr cette pierre
appartenait au tsar de toutes les
russies
le véritable petit père du peuple
les rouges ont volé anna lors de la
tragédie et nous nous en sommes rendu
acquéreur à la mort de cearà cap c'est
mou il ya six mois à londres
mon dieu quelle époque
[Musique]
et maintenant un peu la parole s est en
piste
à cette lumière ça va je peux aller
n'oublie pas tes vacances donc quand il
faut des bacchantes j'ai oublié tête de
la reconnaître un vrai constat mélo
général castagnet toskala
[Musique]
vous avez toujours ces diamants gens qui
que j'ai admiré beaucoup d'autres jours
dans votre vitrine
il était de tradition
si des sages que l'oxo offre 10 km
qu'auront du breton de pierre je mène
l'une à la naissance lourde pour ses 20
ans en souvenir des services rendus aux
romanov par l'épaule comme à l'époque
des chevaliers teutoniques
cette pierre s'appelle anne je pensais
olga marqué vu rimer de viarmes au sein
du porno marc dorcel barque sans doute
bien sûr on ne savait pas qui à mon sens
bien à l'entré jeu le sou des grands
ducs de réfugiés des gens que j'ai aidé
par solidarité aristocratique kelly
d'enseignants vous avez perdu toute
chance d'acheter je te piège c'est vous
qui l'affirment mais monsieur le marquis
de commandes car la dame madame et la
grande-duchesse des choux des jus comme
on dit chez vous si j'étais un nom
maintenant appeler votre mari votre
office relevé ian mcphail one more ados
nés cette europe
cholet la grande-duchesse monsieur mark
chichon prix je ne resterai pas monsieur
en mauvaise compagnie vous prie de bien
vouloir m'excuser émanant du chef grande
duchesse ne l'oublié pas tenez voici ma
carte
appelez moi demain je suis prête à
mettre le prix qu'il faudra pour pays
n'avance ont amené la rançon d'anna
c'est bien vous qui l'a gardé en otage
sous la protection des lois de notre
république
ac oui bien sûr je vous appellerai soyez
sans crainte à la blague en descente
bien nous nous rencontrerons peut-être
ailleurs qu'ici je vous expliquerai
voici dans ce fameux diamant jonquilles
que les merveilles qu'elle est finie
c'est une pièce incomparable je veux la
paix senio direct je veux les offrir à
ma femme m bouclé d'oreille dire que
nous n'avons pas la jumelle n'est ce pas
comme ces cas attendez attendez deux
secondes c'est si vous n'êtes pas trop
pressé j'ai peut-être une solution
g j'ai peut-être une solution à
n'importe quel prix seniors le tout bien
sûr ma grand duché vous avez été parfait
où j'ai cru retrouver votre perte
alors quelle classe
ce avions fait tout à l'as de la cote
après la guerre écumez vous voulez dire
comment ça y est tu vois pas ce que vous
auriez pu faire d'autre sur la côte avec
le daron anono père non je trouve tout à
fait inutile de mettre les points sur
les i -p
d'accord on mettra que les accents
circonflexes sur les ballots et [ __ ] non
mais regardez moi cette tronche plate
suis empressé pas de moment c'est
combien cette pierre m'attends pas au 19
avril puisqu'il ou elle est trop la
première partie de l'opération
nous allons être obligés d'avoir recours
à ces canailles 2002 rennes
[Musique]
c'est un du trio ce sera quand ça sera
sec
j'aimais bien vous renoir aubistes un
mois aussi baroness net prend sur le
marché des concurrents malhonnête
cela est vraiment un artiste le dernier
aujourd'hui les jeunes n'y croient plus
qu'à la manière forte et hold up les
rapts toutes les vraies valeurs
s'écroule alors peut-on savoir ce qui
vous amène baroness d'abord le plaisir
de vous voir au bistrot d'antan et
ensuite les ducs ouest du cyrillique
il faudrait que nous meurent produisiez
ça sur parchemin décélère authentique
j'ai déjà fait des mazingues avait pour
les airs authentiques voix nous excusent
augustin non il s'agirait d'un document
signé par nicolas ii en 1915 et il vous
faudrait ça pour quand le plus vite
remuant aller plus vite plus vite vous
me faites marrer mois sur ledit à
rembrandt plus vite quand il faisait sa
ronde de nuit bamert il aurait dit aux
bourgeois d'amsterdam puis l'aurait eu
raison
[Musique]
gérard ce qu'il y a ce n'a rien marqué
tout à l'heure non ça sautait pourtant
aux yeux écoute robert arrête de jouer
aux devinettes
je t'ai déjà dit de ne pas m'appeler
robert ici te plains pas je pourrais
peut-être les bébés alors qu'est ce qui
n'a pas sauté aux yeux tout à l'heure
que la grande duchesse lemarque et
argentat sont de connivence des escrocs
ils nous préparent un coup vieux comme
la troisième république
bien sûr que tu n'es pas au courant on
ne peut pas être fois où il a été au
four gérard chenoz prix alors c'est quoi
au juste cette fameuse escroquerie le
soi-disant argentin se prétend acquéreur
de deux pierres pour offrir des boucles
d'oreilles à sa femme tu as entendu oui
mais ensuite la vieille m'a raconté
qu'elle avait une pierre semblables olga
le soi-disant argentin va nous acheter
jonquilles et la vieille va venir nous
le revendre quelques jours plus tard
beaucoup plus cher et pourtant la veille
a dit tenir énorme comédienne des
gauchos comédienne toute l'astuce et la
nuit à la police
la franchise quelle horreur cet argentin
je vais le procédé comme un petit
séminariste quel appétit monseigneur
est ce que je comprends pas c'est
pourquoi pas dans son magasin bayon
fernand vous ne comprenez rien n'a rien
ce gredin le directeur veut doubler son
patron et réaliser la sphère % propre
camp nou mais sage avait entravé par an
d'un support est pour ça qu ils
préfèrent traiter dans un endroit
discret
si ça réussit ça serait de me rendre
dans des régions comme on si ça réussit
mais ça va réussir fernand morneau
[Musique]
que madame la grande duchesse très bien
soigné le train faire non allez donc
vous faire voir chez les grecs bien
valable a grandi
[Musique]
mes hommages madame la grande duchesse
cher monsieur je suis toujours
reconnaissante à vous d'avoir bien voulu
me donner rendez vous ici plutôt que
notre boutique
je déteste les mauvaises rencontres
c'est top le petit remarqué un vrai mot
gic
je suis sûr qu'il est un escroc
soyez tranquilles nous avons l'oeil pour
détecter les gens de cette espèce
voici le document voilà un tessinois
avec plaisir mais vrai
[Musique]
la cdu cyrillique et lisent-ils de
nicolay à sa cousine catia pour le covan
immémoriale souvenir vous comprenez
maintenant ce canal représente pour moi
[Musique]
que malheureusement madame la grande
duchesse
nous ne pouvons pas prendre en
considération les questions d'ordre
sentimental nous avions parlé de 19
millions 3 à 2 ne m'en veuillez pas trop
madame la grande duchesse mais voilà
depuis votre visite
on nous a fait une offre supérieure le
moujik
non non non non l'offre nous vient d'un
émirat arabe et combien il propose votre
soult à 25
[Musique]
7 au dessus dans mes possibilités
à 20 h au hall
bien sûr
vous pourrez vendre ma maison de madame
la grande duchesse j'ai infiniment mieux
à vous proposer
je vous achète olga vos plaisant et je
l'air de plaisanter
réfléchissez olga sans sa soeur vous
m'avez bien dit qu'elle ne représentait
rien sentimentalement réussir enfin
écoutez je les apprécie je vous achète
olga 300 mille francs bourrique
[Musique]
c'est une somme trente briques 300 mille
francs ont décidément on n'arrivera
jamais à parler à nouveau à aaa
je me fait rire c'est bien de veto -
nous sommes bien d'accord je vous achète
cette pierre à condition que je puisse
avoir dans huit jours monsieur marty
vous avez ma parole à descendre aussi ça
je suis en train de le négocier elle
sera certainement beaucoup plus cher une
pierre qui appartenait au tsar nicolas
ii
ok ça mariano filles avec les boucles
d'oreilles du tsar nicolas ii dans la
ville aux merveilleux à nîmes pour tous
quel prix
signori attend alors vous achetez la
première pierre a tout de suite enchaîné
tôt je reviendrai l'année
je préfère vous payez comptant en
liquide dessus martin mais la maison n'y
vois aucun inconvénient bien et senio ni
le tort j'ai compté sur vous je vendrai
dit mes vaches s'il faut il faudra bien
orama se maquille allenby j'ai campé sur
vous tous
alors je m'amuse comme un fou tu vas
pouvoir me payer mon vision alors c'est
des escargots lait de noix de coco
spécialité des philippines
oui les îles philippines capital que ce
titre au 5000 mètres carrés 30 millions
quatre cent quatre-vingt dix mille
habitants
oui bah je sais tout ça depuis longtemps
de ça n'a pas bien tourné la géographe
et non sa méthode sache tout ça alors ça
y est les moments où je préférerais
avoir un enfant sous doués ou abrutis
satan est pas de complexe le coup tu es
toi que ton père est fatigué et nerveux
parfaitement je suis crevé je suis
épuisée nerveusement et toi pour me
détendre au lieu de me faire d'un bon
steak frites ou des escargots macériens
la note qu'au regard de la petite
regardait même pas ça non plus si une
colle war soit pauline doit pas sa soeur
de même je n'aime pas l'escargot est
loin
allo à wind attentes
oui non ne vous inquiétez pas tout s'est
bien passé aucun problème c'est ça on se
retrouve demain matin à l'institut
moi aussi je vous embrasse envoie
maintenant bonne nuit qu'est ce que tu
voulais c'est une folle d'abord ma tante
n'est pas une vieille folle un peu
malhonnête août au prix de nos jours qui
ne l'est pas ou qu'elles te fait perdre
ton temps avec son institut d'un v6 10
kg et j'ai vu que ça me serve couverture
et que je crois que cette année on va
pouvoir louer une villa en corse au du
pognon monde fait marrer quoique cpeq
mois qu'il faudrait pour toi mon num
croyons rien du tout cher ami enfin quoi
de plus va puisque je te connais j'ai
toujours été réglo justement les
affaires sont plus ce qu'elles ont été
esquissées par constance a fait rien
pour les planètes aux députés n'auront
fall écoute tu nous les prêter 25 bat
ongles ou non je les prends et que les
price je ne pourrais pas moins une fois
un gage
dommage ouais ben j'en tire 20 millions
ça sent le bout du monde
franchement plus de 25 millions savoir
d'où vient le grand duc alexandre mon
beauf
oh ben dites vous fatiguez pas baroness
des histoires russe moi je peux vous à
refourguer un alors moi estime 20 paraît
sous de plus parce que c'est vous parce
que vous êtes des gens bien élevés et
combien de jours vous mais laisserions
honoris vie jours tout au plus
en huit jours alors moi je suis obligé
de prendre du 15 % 15 % à des vieux amis
comme non injustement les vieux amis
faut les choyer et puis dites dorin ou
que celle que vous y allez chercher vos
brique au crédit agricole et qu'on
pourra pas parler pour rien dire là on
est d'accord pour 15%
abbas alors c'est différent vous ne
rendez pas compte qu'elle percepteur
yamakasi sans arrêt il pas d agaceries
érotique
on était moi de vous dire j'y accole des
comptes devant le congrès sans aucun
doute que ce maquis la vidéo
senior director j'écoutais je vous avais
trouvé l'achigan anime pôle tes quel
prix
c'est une même une belle pièce tu vois
bien faire non il va rien à craindre
évidemment pour le moment n'a rien fait
de mal on a acheté un bijou à nous aucun
n'a les ventes
je protège la caraïbe à rodez c'est moi
qui vais accoucher seule avec elle cette
nuit vous avez déjà entendu parler des
cambriolages
il a raison ma tante si on compte sur la
police pour être secouru bon on peut
mourir trois fois des dents le mec de la
bijouterie c'est lui qui doit vous
rappeler je vais lui proposer à car en
convient rapide toute façon je veux dire
n importe quel prix qui va la voir dans
ce cadre merde je vous ai déjà dit bon
mettons dans le baba ca peut vous faire
plaisir baroness oui mais en attendant
il faut se mettre à jour sur les rosaces
de la chance parce qu'on est en retard
la raison on a aussi pas mal de
commandes pour les buvards qui boivent
les fautes d'orthographe pas d'achat des
étudiants
c'est inouï le niveau intellectuel
baisse d'une façon incroyable dans ce
pays alors qu'est ce que tu en penses
eux bien intéressant à dire ce que tu me
dis que c'est pas qu'on soit il excuse
moi j'ai un coup de fil à a donné de
deux secondes je le lirai soit ton
machin à tête reposée comment ça bon
d'achat à l'eau seniors martin et moi
oui j'ai tout d'abord ce qui se passe au
sujet des lattes en fait âgée suis
impatient mardi aux lois senior director
seignol maritime
qu'est ce qui te prend comme que rien à
vous dis non c'est avec un copain on
joue aux accents oui lui prend l'accent
russe
moi je prends la sens argentin en rigole
alleaume attentes
oui et moi oui ah oui oui bah je suis
d'accord avec vous ça traîne trop hein
mais je vas juste j'allais vous le
demandez si vous n'appelez ce soir à 6h
mine de rien oui voit trop jeune je
compte sur vous c'est ça or moi je vous
envoie ce matin je trouve que c'est les
affaires cécile les affaires tu te rends
pas compte qu'ils vont comme fric avec
deux femmes quatre enfants et avec moi
c'est ce qu'ont bien ça fait 7 à loger
nourrir vêtir et emmener en vacances et
tu me le reproche
je leur reproche pas je constate je le
déplore un poids de tout site il déplore
c'est que tu le regrette
et si tu ne regrettes alors moi aussi je
m à le regretter super non
je regrette rien de toute façon pour mon
équilibre il faut que je puisse finir
mon livre que j'ai publié
si ça devient un best-seller je reste
ici à garder les gosses je deviens dont
un objet et sans complexe travail dgt à
monsieur martin mais je m'arrache et
larmes à 300 mille francs
votre offre m'intéresse pas
j'ai bien réfléchi les temps sont
difficiles et bien comme la dernière
fois je vous amène vrai ma chère aux
regards c'est entendu monsieur à tout à
l'heure
donc comment l'animal est rôti ap
quelques années ce type
ça me fait bien plaisir de faire justice
pour une fois ils demandent jusqu'à
demain matin pour expertiser le caillou
normal on pourrait dire union qui
cherchent ailleurs fils et le garde et
[Musique]
alors qu'en pensez vous monsieur le
directeur
ce que j'en pense madame la grande
duchesse vous allez bientôt le savoir
dans les lignes n cette pierre est
magnifique mais je vous défie d'en
obtenir plus de 150 franchisés mes
confrères cent cinquante mille fois mais
on avait bien dit
trois cent mille madame la grande
duchesse
auriez vous laissez votre accent et
votre noblesse au vestiaire ne craignez
rien le criant chers amis je n'ai pas
prévenu la police
la police quelle police mais si duchesse
de la courneuve baronne de fleury
merogis vous ne comprenez parfaitement
votre ami le marquis le moujik très
distingué ce monsieur que je ne reverrai
sans doute jamais fait lui tous les
compliments 150000 france tu as compris
réfléchissez dans l'opération vous ne
perdez xing briques estimez-vous
heureuse garçons arnaqueurs je vous dois
38 faute à 150000 je suis preneur
discrètement sans histoire téléphoner
moi dès que vous serez décidé je serai
toujours madame la grande duchesse votre
humble serviteur
car à chaud finalement on bosse autant
qu'à luz il avec tout vos conneries je
n'ai jamais compte en faire non
comment vous appelez ça un coup fumant
ou se faire passer de 5 briques 1
il vous a fallu six mois de méditation
au courant les oiseaux pour trouver ça
et ça va faire non tu peux nous en
pondre une trame gothique et tout ce
cargo
garbouj n'offre aucun doute je vous
avais prévenu non non il ya des jours où
je me demande si je ferais pas mieux de
redevenir honnête non je me demande
quelle administration accepterait vos
références sur bristol judiciaire avec
la poudre aphrodisiaques
on va finir par éponger nous aide parce
que ça c'est un bon truc là bon truc
production tous les clients deviennent
par un puissant n'exagérons rien
6 1 et stimule pas ça ne peut pas
l'envers c'est peut-être laxatifs
personne va tester
moi je réfléchis depuis ce coup
malheureuse des gens qui jouent bien
finir par tourner quelque chose parce
que j'ai chez moi ça urge
quel chez toi tu précises jamais ben oui
parce que c'est les deux ouais bon - les
gonzesses jeumont et environs de repas
dès que j'ai consommé virer au zizek
entendre des choses pareilles j'en
deviendrais mêlait n'oublie pas de mai
c'est le fric pour le loyer
[Musique]
c'est tout à tuchan ce moment c'est
difficile et u11 paie pas dans un mois
tout va s'arranger et moi j'aurai fini
mon livre alors à l'avenir est à nous
[Musique]
le
j'ai été réveillée parce que c'est la
viande milan qui a eu du retard mais
c'est les italiens avec leurs oreilles
or là il est gentil si tu manques tu
m'aimes tu ne te crever sans neige et
une affaire terrible
il ya eu enfin sera contraignant puisque
c'est long mais je suis probablement pas
aux compagnies - place aux du cem série
que s'est vu dans un journal une
publicité pour une poudre aphrodisiaques
bio tellurique du cgi
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
e
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est toi chérie je n'ai pas vu de
réveiller ce matin parce que tu es
rentré tellement bas tu as bien fait
j'étais sur un cool jure sur une mission
infernal je peux pas tous les dix ans
non non non non non on suit un diplôme
suppose qu'ils poseraient renseignements
à l'est on n'est pas bien sûr dis donc
qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est du chute
même à la badigeonner et doit faire ça
canaris se marie bien à l'ailé alors on
va dit niet ah bon il est un doux sont
arides pas du tout il est de 5 jours je
vois pas pourquoi il ne devrait pas la
cousinade ou oui j'ai dans l'idée si une
bonne idée je vais faire de la pâte de
carottes sucré oui ça c'est pas très bon
pour pour ta ligne bagot
à midi je mange juste une toute petite
salade et puis c'est toujours ainsi donc
chiffrement le propriétaire a téléphoné
alors ils réclament la seconde partie
pour l'appartement
alors je lui dise attend jusqu'à la fin
du mois tu vois si tu avais pris à
crédit comme tout le monde passait après
tout ne m'écoute j'avais déjà dit un
agent des services secrets n'a pas le
droit de prendre un crédit
donc ne demande pas plus le principal
c'est que je me débrouille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons vous êtes toutes et tous
nous et tous alors cette chienlit qui
veut nous empêcher de travailler à
domicile avec leurs bombes et les filles
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent les flics
j'aurais téléphoné sont arrivés tous
deux sont là alors capitaine que vous
attendez pour ça votre boulot il doit
cette racaille lots à ce que son simple
nom n'a pas plus pour faire de la
philosophie
je
qu'est ce que vous foutez là vous et je
suivais que hilton jean-jacques mon
petit dieu non seulement vous ne foutez
rien mais en plus vous voulez empêcher
mais je voyais travailler gagner leur
vie
la manifestation anti-lgv et on n'est
pas dirigée contre vous jouez bien même
on est là pour défendre la nature
j'ai l'autorisation de travaux publics
le permis de construire mon petit
bonhomme et personnellement milieux de
l'environnement pour qu'il empêche cet
assassinat alors si tu ne sais pas car
agathe est la vache a créé culot du
fumier avec elle connaît au body vais
pas finir aux produits adéquats en mélo
je te colle qu'elle touche en retraite
incombe aux salopards de fait perdre du
fric par jour et en plus j'ai la
prétention
l'entretien est complètement à côté du
problème comme mon propre jantes empêché
les ouvriers travaillent et de
l'écologie quel robinet afrique ferme et
patata l'opa cet âge il ajouté tu as
fifrelin avec les peintures de merde on
va voir si tu peux te payer deux fois
grâce à travailler tôt
surtout pas parler comme ça à moi alors
chaque combattant chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
ob préférable de partir ça partait la da
cunha vous mettre au courant
voser patron admis nabeul temps de lundi
c'est pas fini ce temps là mon petit
montalban rien savoir de quel bois se
sont démarqués au revoir je pense là
pour le pognon va falloir attendre
quelques jours
1 combien les intérêts à 20% comme la
vie augmente de 15 mois il faut bien que
ces jeux tels que le show sur 10
millions ça va vous faire un joli
bénéfice aubin si ça vous plaît pas
adressez vous à la caisse d'epargne ont
traduit agricole moyenne mais la
concurrence toujours vaux-villaine
réflexion quand on possède si joli show
mais laissez ça c'est rien vous pourriez
les mettre en valeur
alors ils s'abîment rey à la lumière
pour les 6 à 2013 d'où ils viennent d'où
qu'ils viennent et l'afrique d'amérique
du sud de ce que ce nom se doit
ça se revend très bien les papillons moi
je connais un à l'amateur moteur d'isf
un e-reçu
bon ben alors score magnifique rivaux ça
pourrait plaire à alix guise but alexis
ce vieil ami de longue date que je
rencontre de temps en temps au tél je
vous en ai pas oui il collectionne les
papillons c'est son violon dingue il a
dû blimp collectionneurs augustin vous
devriez savoir depuis longtemps que je
ne fréquente pas les clochards
c
at il pas toujours marrer toi mon cher
ami si les bonnes manières dont la veine
iliaque au jazz des vignes ou un petit
biscuit bien tassés il paraît que ça dit
soulevant les siens n'a pas toujours
plusieurs de voir si elle me rappelle le
beau temps qu'est ce que tu en penses
quoi ils sont prêts à faire un super six
a bien regardé ce n'est pas vos
magnifiques demande même pourquoi tu
veux t'en sais pas quelques difficultés
financières alexis les choses garrigole
extraordinaires y en a beaucoup diminué
mais je suis tranquille où le banquier
du ballet clément très pinault qu'est ce
qu'il vient faire là les banques et
trépidant sur l'appartement a été
cambriolée ya trois ans c'est papillon
ce sont en fait les petits frères et
soeurs
je vois deux cas toujours de mauvaises
fréquentations ne changera jamais les
paroles ce temps c'est bien ce qui me
désespère
et donc tu connu et qu'un sur deux
tribunaux non c'est un ami d'un ami tim
a précédemment
si tu pouvais me faire rencontrer
quelques coupeur de têtes ça m'intéresse
des coupeurs de tête la dure des vrais
de vrai ce polyglotte faut des tueurs je
ne connais pas peut-être pourquoi faire
des terres mais pour tuer le temps d un
temps tu es un petit con tu sympa dit
n'y va pas par quatre chemins la
comprend le baronne suis pas ici baronne
et
hier
l'opération écologique antibes et ont
dirigé contre les projets destructeurs
du groupe immobilier piedboeuf a
pleinement réussi mardi à 6 heures du
matin 200 cyclistes arrivée au bras de
clamart et par leurs actions de
résistance passive aux engins de mort
des coupeurs d'arbres empêcher la
poursuite du massacre de dizaines de
centaines de chaises d'innocents le
ministère de l'environnement donnera sa
réponse dans les jours prochains
tu sais tu es tout seul un petit connard
peugeot en grèce qui se prend pour
picasso mon propre chemin entre est ta
fille qu'est ce qu'elle en dit à megève
a mais fera bien entendu de toute façon
tout ce qu'il raconte tout ce qu'il dit
tout ce qu'il fait ce sont paroles
d'évangile
monsieur est un artiste et moi j'en ai
marre faut bien que jeunesse se passe
et le plus vite possible zubar homme a
fait vif c'est ton jaune que tu veux si
tu veux te trouve de bons ouvriers pour
ce petit travail baronne jolie tu auras
beau bouquet un bouquet de biais de
porte
ce sont les fleurs que tu préfères si
j'ai bonne mémoire de même
alexis née roth
tu sais bien que j'aime aussi les rangs
on aura par tuer le marché de vote soit
ça dépend du prix qu'il veut mettre une
drôle d'idée que vous avez eu l'âme
ma tante j'ai pensé avec 10 millions en
mai mais il peut payer l'immobilier si
vous voyez sa propriété après la guerre
il est allé à saïx bon si là où il a
fait fortune en pratiquant l'épia et la
pénicilline belle figure d'un très fort
lui ai promis quoi exactement de lui
trouver les âmes dont il a besoin mais
on sent on n'est pas des tueurs
il faut savoir s'adapter aux
circonstances
oh non c'est pas facile je suis une
bonne
calme-toi qu'est ce que j'écris comme
pas le but c'est dingue c'est très bien
pour le but il écrit très bien
en attendant voilà toujours ton chèque
commence à monter oui enfin le chèque
pour ton séjour avec les enfants chez ta
mère
ça dérange pas j'aimerais que tu
attendes lundi prochain avant de mettre
à la banque
ça ne marche pas de ses affaires en ce
moment j'ai quelques difficultés et moi
la vérité quelle vérité du produit des
films pornos 1 c'est ça c'est pour ça
que tim nota que j'aille aux projections
beaucoup citent assure cécile et c'est
pour ça que tu veux jamais me faire
tourner bon enfin su suivre dans logic
enfin pense pensa à tes enfants à nos
enfants à ta mère on va pas falloir rien
à voir là dedans alors cette chose de me
faire tourner dans un film porno mais ça
ne choque pas trompé sa femme alors
espèce de sale phallocrate avec le
gouvernement s'inquiète des journaux
féministe toi tu trouves ça normal de
m'empêcher de l'assumer c'est pas en
tant les films pornos que tu assumeras
c'est au contraire j'assume complètement
la condition féminine
je livre est ce que tu fais vivre aux
autres soit en deux secondes ça c'est
super mais je t'assure saisie du v10 est
absurde
je ne produis pas des films pornos je
vends des courts métrages japonais au
tchécoslovaque
ah oui mais voilà la chute à savoir le
sud ce sera mieux chez ta merde
quinze jours ça te fera le plus grand
bien j'ai senti chez aux beats audio
lorsque la haute fréquence c'est spécial
comme techniques appropriées pour tous a
inutilement d'une part on peut
intervenir si tu as un pépin et d'autre
part ça peut nous servir de preuve si
jamais ça tournait mal
et pourquoi voulez vous c'est normal on
prend jamais assez de précautions mais
leur aide à sa césure jamais quand
l'enfant raison allez j'y vais
[Musique]
andré malraux à aix nice revient seul il
y à terme un souvenir que je préfère
écarter sa famille tous les métros de
tempérament il est vrai que je savais me
prend incommensurable vanité masculine
nommé tu ne t'es jamais demandé si je ne
jouais pas la commune allant cocotte tu
as de telle ou telle partie cris d' on
n'est pas poussée des imitations jusque
là
sympa non
il est tard ton cul s'il viendra parole
de corps voici la personne dont je vous
ai parlé alexis aujourd'hui c'est le
client c'est le client asseyez-vous dont
il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas tout
va très bien madame la marquise tout va
très bien mais je dois d'avoir un peu de
moralité non je ne vous demande pas à
proprement parler de faire une mauvaise
action de parole n'a dit que vous étiez
paraître sérieux conscience
professionnelle envers des références il
ne risque pas de venir grossir les rangs
des emplois
dégagé le nom roderick il a fait ça
toute sa vie
bref l'histoire chaque fois ça pour tous
est très mauvaise
voilà le [ __ ] et l'utile points
actuellement me fait qu'un petit million
par jour
walcott et messieurs je voudrais que
vous dit fassi faire des économies c'est
votre fils
non mon genre je préfère lui aussi alors
votre prix voulais juste qu'ils
disparaissent
ah oui vas pas autre chose on pourrait
le faire quelques petites gâteries avant
le talent pas avec un petit supplément
leur sera comme ça juste comprendre le
travail au tarif syndicats le syndicat
du crime n'a rien à voir avec la cgt
par crainte à avoir alexis ça vous
faudra donc 300 mais le flanc vous
conscient attention c'est entendu vous
avez une préférence pour l'exécution du
contrat mais je voudrais savoir si tu
préfères ce petit travail ou au revolver
au couteau à la main et accorde pourtant
c'est pour le mieux
ensuite on vous le choléra dans le béton
à l'américaine ça évitera les frais
d'enterrement le béton je peux vous le
fournir un tutoiement
[Rires]
je coupe la poire en deux temps pire
regard c'est toi que j'ai pas confiance
mais on sait jamais eu de moitié après
une moitié avant très bien c'est normal
mais monsieur a besoin d'un petit à
valoir pour ces faux frais j'ai du
personnel qu'il ne peut pas déclarer
évidemment à la sécurité sociale et ça
c'est plutôt un avantage combien des
petites unités pour toi c'est un
pourboire et mahler a coûté du fric
saveurs dans une semaine votre jambe il
sera coulé dans le béton par le dos ni
la taille est telle qu'elle prenne un
portrait vous les oreilles et la queue
pour remporter moi simplement sont ses
papiers ça monte
non son alliance elle est gravé à
l'intérieur son nom n'ayez aucune
crainte que le travail soit fait
correctement évident le pot qui souffle
je te reconnais bien là alexis et ben je
dois reconnaître que tu es parti genou
oui mais maintenant vouloir tenir
puisque j'ai donné ma parole au dedans
j'ai lu ton article il ya dans le monde
à ses pairs qu'est ce que tu lis pas
satan contraire à celle de joe wright
le chanteur deryck par jour dont une
body bon alors cela je le serai toujours
attendre la semaine prochaine et ta
femme qu'est ce qu'elle en pense bête à
megève pour autant vim je suis ravie
fauconnet trop cher monsieur
afin de mieux pouvoir vous féliciter
devant tout cela on reste sans voix
new castrol comme spirituelle s'est-il
ivory laquelle elle apostrophe ans c'est
très dépouillée très simples comme
mozart mais rendre le réel tel qu'il est
tel est le but du supra pop qui s'appuie
sur une perception directe et naturel de
la réalité afin de mieux vendre aux
afin de mieux les branlées j'adore cette
formule j'ai commis avant d'épouser
petites merveilles est bien celui là car
celui-là 6000 il a fallu rendre la
matière vivante vous comprenez le sheikh
madame comprend mieux que vous ne pouvez
le penser géant messieurs
d'ailleurs votre réputation n'est déjà
plus à faire et bien je vous prends là
que la caste rhône et la poire et je
veux arriver une symbiose totale
je vous ai compris que vous alliez chez
moi j'aimerais que ce qui bouge pas mal
que c'est ça va pas fermer ta gueule
sinon cela prend du plomb de petite tête
d'article c'est une plaisanterie
l'ancien stade enlèvement
j'ai renoncé aimable jetez moi une
station de taxis
je préfère me battre et au dépeçage de
la mer mais avant
il
je
mais
il est où
ah les autres
[Musique]
vous voulez une rançon tom beau-père
nous donnerait peut-être 200 millions
regroupés à une des tests on le sait
puisque c'est lui qui nous a payés
porterez la bahia où le [ __ ] salut ou
pas on est obligé de te descendre on
était des assassins mais on n'est pas
malade nous vite y est je suis un
artiste vous pouvez pas tuer un artiste
s'il fallait s'occuper de ça on n'en
finirait plus pas vrai et jo tu es un
artiste huawei et bachand tenue
d'élections je suis pas chaud chaud
c'est pas chanter quoi atépa pas si tu
peux pas mettre tous mais tata toutes
mes tableaux je vous les donne
ah oui je voudrais en fuite deux
tableaux de l'artiste ya peut être moyen
de moyenner mais faudra bien faire ce
qu'on va te dis oui
tout tout tout tu veux arrêter de bagel
de bafouiller comme ça et payer ça
m'énerve moi aussi ça me jette alors on
va tout expliquer mais tu veux de ne pas
faire dans toulouse je le jure je crois
toujours sur mon art veut pas passer ton
beau père et non plus on préfère ta
femme d'accord oui sur la tête donne sur
la tête tonnes mais du don que nous
avons fait un comptoir attention mais
non mais non c'est le prénom de ma femme
[Musique]
et
allez debout l'adorent qu'est-ce que tu
bois le matin du t bond des cafés
japonica sur le fronton bah voila mon
bonheur
on évitera de faire la vaisselle tu vois
plutôt les touchés par la structure non
mattiello pourquoi c'est un gymnase et
une casserole
non c'est plus une casserole veulent
être sorti de son état d'infériorité
utilitaires et vas y retourne
y a pas de mal à ça selon 400 artistique
on attendant bon sens artistique doit
faire la vaisselle
aucune raison de choix dont l'arbre il
ya été sages n'ont pas plus que ça
qu'ils soient passage tu as vu la borne
est oui alors le beau père est parti
pour le kenya chasse aux papillons qui
se ménage amélie roy que lors du rck
dis donc toi le leurs deux passions
tapas aller à la plonge j'en ai marre je
décidé de coopérer avec vous vous devez
me traiter d'égal à égal
j'suis autres complices complice alors
tu fais rien n'est fait c'est le conclut
ce jeu même ben ali même pas brosse à
dos sinon moi aussi je commence à en
avoir plein que toi tu es 4 l'artistique
a appris qu'on allait boss
si je savais avec les gosses anneaux et
moi alors je hais
[Applaudissements]
oui mon petit copain pas arrêtée aux
amateurs attendus j'espère qu'ils
aimeront points vous venez l'essayer
pose pas de questions moelleux est ce
que ça te conviens mais voilà ta la
cuisine la salle de bain la ouais ouais
la balle est donc bien vos coudes pour
jour dans les bidonvilles qui pourrait
bien voir sa voix il veut qu aux effets
faisait du tout de suite de tabarre
ouais y'a tombola ville veut qu'on
ramène un scalpeur non pas à bouche pas
mais un reste tranquille bon dieu non ça
tu m'aimes mieux question de couper une
patinoire
c'est une atteinte à la personne humaine
ça repousse pas nous pendu dépendu ça y
est c'est fini
bon bah dis donc si on avait celle de
karl marx comme ça on se font au moins
autant de fric que le froc d'hitler
maintenant ma barbe aux yeux si avec ça
tu l'a séduite
alors maintenant tu vas être sage et
tout ce qu'il faut un salle de bain pour
te raser demain et apporte à bouffer à
l'état de droit qu'il est mais pourquoi
toi tu es
vous m'en fermé du long on a confiance
en toi mais ya des limites à ciao un
conseil faites pas le camp
[Musique]
c'est bien qu'un métier c'est ça ne
paraît pas non plus fait déchanter près
de fresnes
tu connais ça ferait la ruche pourraient
commencer un tunnel en partant
l'extérieur ça pourrait nous servir des
pins contre acer marron
[Musique]
tous
et
qui
oula
et un dieu pour les alésiens je te
dépose devait voter du riscle non
ma pote carmen ruiz ou ce n'est pas
envie de me pieuter
c'est toi à moi je vais aller voir si
mentalement et je tiens tranquille
l'instinct
j'étais fatigué mon gros nounours
il posait son gros dedans mais on va
quand même le réveiller a fait pour
faire un gros câlin ça fait tilt
voilà madame n'ayez pas peur je pourrais
pas bonne je suis averti
n'approchez pas ne me touchez pas je
veux pas vous toucher si vous touchez
vous aurez affaire à un ami proche est à
la limite mais je vous demande d'y aller
c'est un malentendu
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout ça
qu'est ce que vous faites et seychellois
dans mon lit président n'ont pas dit on
à la sortie mais il veut pas sortir si
jamais je sors les gants stériles nombre
d'efforts dans certaines sphères vous
êtes fous ils vont revenir ce qui m'a
amené ici et dans ce cas vous aurez à
mener si vous prenez pour une idiote
mais non ils m'ont dit que je pouvais
confie six mois j'ai plus grand lit je
peux bien ferme
excusez moi non mais d'écouter n'ayez
pas peur surtout je ne veux aucun mal
voyez je m'assois non non non non pas le
17 je vous en supplie c'est un défi qu
alors vous êtes un voleur mais non je
suis pas un voleur je veux un artiste
méconnu peut-être mais pas un voleur
alors ne vous choque pas mais je ne veux
pas de mal oh là là je n'ai plus le
droit de nous raconter son salaire
décent mais qui vous a mené ici je me
suis rangé sans complice ils m'ont bandé
les yeux baissés des morts de tristes
ouah je ne connais pas de monsieur il
avait les clés
alors commence à qui je suis mais je
suis ici chez moi devant la propriété on
sort partout un grand prix intéressant à
écouter ces suivis vous n'allez pas me
donner des leçons il était comment ce
monsieur ange non non je peux pas vous
en dire plus et limon ma vie non mais
rassurez vous je ne vous veux pas de mal
je suis à abattre de vraiment je pense
mettez vous à ma place je vous trouve
dans mon livre mais j'étais en train de
dormir ça prouve que j'avais pas de
mauvaises intentions
quand même m'expliquer au but the jolly
en plus chez bosch j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un rêve
et bien ne rêvez pas trop quand même et
puis quoi encore ah oui ce qui rend plus
grand d'entre eux condamnés
extraordinaire ça donnait bon résumons
vous n'êtes pas trop bas d'ailleurs je
vais prendre mes voeux oui non
enfin ça c'est super des dents c'est pop
ce propos je trouve ça très beau c'est
en dehors du beau et du laid je place
des objets utilitaires dans un contexte
débarrasser de sa valeur pratique je
fais des recherches moi aussi eu un beau
succès monsieur appelez moi georges
abbou sait comment cécile
on attend que ça veut dire que tu fais
ici
ok tout seul ça mais dis donc c'est
plutôt à moi de demander qu'est ce que
c'est ça arrange tant que force est
d'abord qu'est ce qu'il fait ici suis là
quand je fais tu veux te genres entre
eux explique moi ce que c'est que ces
histoires bonser séquenceur bel et bien
dit que des gangsters voulez vous tuer
oui si oui ce sont des gangsters se
pourrait qu'ils aient caché ici tu
aurais pu me prévenir
et je pouvais pas savoir que je
reviendrai si vite je me suis engueulé
avec ma mère elle un caractère
impossible mais comment tu as connu jean
jacques jaujac situent à pau
jean-jacques faucher pas l'appli
napoléon de tomates ou même vous
connaissez pas aux yeux ou tabou chez
toi la sp quoi ça sert je suis rentré à
minuit de la gare d'austerlitz et j'ai
eu la surprise de trouver ce monsieur
dans mon lit sans le canapé j'étais pas
très bien ensuite ensuite à 6,38
schipper moi je veux me couche avec lui
mehdi baala bateau là alors tu
t'imagines que je fais l'amour comme ça
avec le premier type que je trouve dans
mon lit oui ça a été le contraire si moi
je vais avec la fille que tu es le seul
hic
et tout ça tout seul wagon stars ont
fini de l'histoire narre de ta jalousie
de fallon dollar marre de ces amicaux
ducation limousin mais tu vas mais c'est
pas ton ami c'est pour habib sy sall on
vient de me dire moi salo g devant lui
et courtois tu la fermes
tu es un copain de régiment à moi et du
mieux mais envie de te cacher c'est tout
avant ce que tu veux tu sais pas
pourquoi tu es ici sur tous ces noms des
sans abri qu'est ce que ça veut dire
tout ça qu elle vêtue mais norbert trêve
de plaisanterie tu penses bien de jean
jacques et ici c'est qu'il est
réellement en danger de mort c'est ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
donc ils restent ici tu me demande même
pas mon avis si ça me fait plaisir
tu crois ça fait plaisir à moins un mais
on peut vraiment pas faire autrement
ça oui vous êtes content j'avais à faire
monsieur le conservateur a bien raison
tellement de gens malhonnêtes en ce
moment cherche une poêle a marre on sait
pas les barreaux déjà le bâtiment la
main pourquoi foot une fois la mort
d'affaires à nos remarques et un peu
comme toi il n'aime pas qu'on touche à
ces affirmons plus à l'est cherchent
aussi une bassine noir en cuir on se
place leader pour le moment en plus non
plus maintenant j'ai dû faire face à une
grand-mère serge internet est fait
toujours voix basse et berlin tu crois
que tu vas pouvoir faire des tableaux
avec ça
écoute j'ai motors qui les mains
occupées surtout quand je parle à la
levée quel gâchis
j'ai l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas dit
grand chose
c'est l'homme du secret non et vous
voulez que je vous ai c'est le coeur
vous en dit alors comme ça vous vécu les
eaux je me cherche
j'ai d'abord pas des vieux meubles j'ai
fait des poèmes sur pierre brute et je
me suis dit ou fait douter vous êtes une
artiste joue on se dit tu vous ça fait
qu'on un ok alors maintenant tu fais
quoi
un roman un anti roman à un roman oui
comme il y à la peinture
toi tu fais de la peinture me définis
beaucoup trop hâtivement je suis content
chaque tuerie ce que de le traumatisé il
faut bien qu'il s'exprime on suit
maintenant ce qu'est ce que c'est que
tout ça c'est des oeuvres d'art annoncée
pour les tableaux de monde allemand vous
avez une nouvelle de piedboeuf devait
rentrer demain mais avec la grève des
aiguilleurs du ciel chez papy jouera
bien que ça finisse
depuis que je suis née à anglet ça pose
des problèmes de cohabitation
seriez vous a déjà loupé des noms mais
avouez que c'est pas agréable pour
cécile ça c'est une affaire de poignet
ouais et les gonesse qui adore le
d'artistes on est un peu débile a connu
bien que ce soit le secondaire il est en
séries dis donc toi t'es pas ici pendant
ces six prévenus séka séka à l'egypte
allait annoncer tout ça nous a vraiment
plu non espèce de ballon match aux
minots tu vas être habile et habille toi
hein
mieux c'est du passé de l'histoire est
née conçu par des hans
ce film a été tourné mais jeanjean on
pourrait faire l'amour tout mais toi
qu'est ce que tu en penses tu vois ce
que j'en pense tiens c'est pas que vous
en êtes totalement merde comme cela
[Musique]
oui
endemol
[Musique]
8h20 justement j'ai pris la banque de
tous appelé antille elle gère mes
affaires rien n'est simple
on peut régler votre vote tu fais jamila
ben quand elle est fan on a découvert
oui dans deux ou trois jours plus tard
tout se remet en mouvement
à l'arrivée ça va le laisser faire comme
ça ils trouvent pour sa classe alors fut
de faire monter parce que les trop
jeunes c'est inouï tout d'un coup de
quatre manches et un petit peu de salade
de boeuf au banana je vais faire
réchauffer la daube et voit que ça
marche bien et voilà
oui ma tante
il est rentré ce soir bon bah je vais
m'arranger mais bon alors écoutez fixé
lui le rendez-vous à 00h01 fait d'accord
et vous avertit ses airs non c'est
d'accord je compte sur vous maintenant
très bien on voit alors sa chance et mon
boss qui m'appelle encore une mission un
truc urgent ils vont y aller je vous
avais s'accentuera droit à une
permission
[Musique]
et teinté lantern et
détente à nous aussi oui mais lui de
vrais talents
ça va être chaud ici
[Musique]
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la barre haut mais ce qui a dit
faire ça ces cas-là on y va t'es sur qui
laissa on verra bien
[Musique]
on a failli attendre monsieur pierre
j'étais retenu renard en afrique pour
mes affaires en s'en faut vous avez ce
qu'il faut et vous
[Musique]
reste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tant pis tous les dom monsieur kember
c'est votre travail
nous sommes que des exécutants mais
quand même dire que vous l'avez mis
vivent maintenant qu'est ce que ça peut
vous faire à moi rien c'est à dire on
n'est pas là pour cause et alors les
billets il faudrait peut-être d'abord
terminer le travail
mettez la main à la pâte jeu pour
habiller pour ça nous non plus l afrique
l'afrique
vous pouvez vérifier le compte y est
s'ils n'étaient pas monsieur piedboeuf
on les amis même au kenya
adatia
plus vite le feu on sait jamais ils
pourraient nous suivre au tuc unis
seront là sinon tu me dépose en premier
tu diras m'attendre que tu as encore moi
qui vais faire tout le boulot
quel boulot l'état le baril vont pas se
coller tout seul rush cadres et demain
les groupes groupe
c'est pas le moment grillé un feu rouge
non ça ne vaut rien est déjà loin je
pose jal mince je t'accompagne des fois
que mentalement ça dans le montana pour
l'euro de coûts dans ce drôle les vite
vite
c'est là
je crois que j'ai oublié mes clés lors
j'ai enlevé mes chaussures
tu es folle c'est moi c'est toi
oui je suis prêt oui c'est moi mais
qu'est ce que tu fais comme ça comme ça
déguisés je sais pas j'ai boîte si oui
non c'est parce que là je jeu mais comme
il faut quand je vais dans le monde
quel monde qu'est ce qu'il fout là toi
je t'ai pas sonné à crier veut va te
coucher je te dis pas revenir dans la
chambre tu fais ce que je te dis mais la
bio secours et bien même ses appels au
secours allez dégage tu vas te coucher à
les donner quand même bonne nuit
allez hop faut pas crier comme ça pour
rien alors c'est toi comme moi et
gangsters inquiète dexter c'est toi qui
renseigne jean-jacques j'ai tout compris
mais tu tout quoi on le repère mon nom
pas très content
j'aurais dû m'en douter petit bébé
dangereusement 8 que tu risque est à vis
en france
qu'est ce qui te prend qu'est ce tu
racontes là allez va je ne te poserait
plus de questions et moi très fort non
non c'est très fort pour moi
moi je tape sur un boyau jean-jacques
n'a pas pu être enlevés par les femmes
ça sent encore été très distingué avec
un face à face à eaunes on a tous si
c'était un petit zapping ravisseurs ont
fait déjà téléphoné pour demander une
rançon qui tue en afrique et moi à
megève pour le travail l'évidence la
petite jean jacques et instable
caractériel tu dis ça parce que tu le
détestes ce à quoi j'ai un jour mon nom
de dieu m'a fait une fugue pas tout avec
de cqi un bonhomme peut-être de vos
jours c'est odieux papa c'est très
simple s'il ne ramène pas le domicile
conjugal tu pourras demandé le divorce
et songe et tant mieux si ça avec
christian dago histoire en gt à faire
les tiennent surtout pas celle qu'un
type comme montalban tu aurais fini tu
as hell ou à l'armée du salut à
katmandou
[Musique]
me jean jacques
apple avait de l'envié j'ai appelé mon
exposition anti plus anti de la liberté
car mon propos en tant qu'artiste
intégral consiste à sustenter lisez la
nature objets dans un sens anti
transcendantale ma démarche consiste à
inverser le processus traditionnel de la
création partant du créé pour aboutir au
nom créé et qui devient par lui même
l'objet de son contraire
heureux d'ouvrir ses fidèles le boulet
sont mes tableaux soit sa dernière joie
vous comprenez n'est ce pas
[Musique]
à côté d'un parlementaire
c'est marie qui est amusant c'est
puissant noah
si ces [ __ ] au léger incident a eu
lieu à l'occasion du vernissage de
l'exposition anti plus anti égale
liberté du peintre jean-jacques
montalban heureusement nos caméras et
noir aux commissions attention s'arrêter
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]